Of course, even with my body like this, I can do my job without any problems, so don't
worry.
I will definitely find the person who killed your wife. Thank you
very much. Before that, let me
carry your luggage. Alfred, don't worry, I
'll let you carry
my trunk.  I forgot, but you
can carry it yourself.
Yes, Aya-sama. I'm
late in introducing that maid. Her name is
Shizuku-san. Now, Aya,
Rindou. I
thought the story didn't make sense. She has
n't been researching about us in the ancient religion.
Wasn't it? I did some research, but I
couldn't find anything specific, and I
guess the people who were involved with me probably thought they wouldn't believe me even if I told others. Hey
Tsugaru,
this
is my Prime Minister.  Masu